on en parlait il y a quelques instants
de nombreux postes sont à pourvoir en
vue des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
pour en parler avec nous Zora Douchy la
directrice du pôle emploi de Versailles
et Émilie Barad directrice pédagogique
de l'école européenne de sécurité privée
alors dans le cadre de cette grande
campagne de recrutement pour les JO de
Paris 2024 Pôle Emploi propose une
formation gratuite et rémunéré pour pour
les jeunes qui souhaitent devenir agent
de sécurité événementiel comment ça se
passe concrètement alors nous avons deux
types de formation nous avons une
formation qui va être en lien avec
l'école européenne de la de la sécurité
donc des formations sur le SSIAP et là
je vous laisse rien en parler beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus dans le détail donc
des formations pour tous les demandeurs
d'emploi et ensuite il y a la formation
sur les grands événements qui est une
formation beaucoup plus allégée sans six
heures de mémoire 106 heures de
formation 106 heures c'est combien de
semaines environ 3 semaines c'est très
court c'est très devenir agent de
sécurité en trois semaines c'est une
formation qui est vraiment axée sur
l'événementiel sur les JO ensuite bien
entendu les personnes qui souhaitent
aller plus loin dans cette action de
formation pour être agent de sécurité
avec une habilitation qui est délivrée
sur une plus longue durée bon avoir une
formation complémentaire donc vraiment
deux choses une formation classique donc
CQP
et d'autres formations qui sont plutôt
ciblées en direction des étudiants qui
vont pouvoir aussi apporter leur
contribution lors de cet événement des
JO 2024 sur un temps donné et ça leur
permet d'avoir une opportunité des
expériences complémentaires et donc si
elles font cette formation quelles sont
les tâches qu'on pourra leur confier
pendant ces jeux olympiques
nous sommes sur de l'accueil oui alors
les personnes qui vont avoir fait le CQP
psge donc qui est spécialisé grand
événements vont être plus sur du du
contrôle à l'accueil vraiment sur la
partie événementielle il y a toute une
une partie du métier auquel ils ne vont
pas avoir accès parce qu'ils n'ont pas
justement cette formation longue
en fait
il y a beaucoup
ce sont des formations qui fonctionnent
en UV
est-ce que de valeur excusez il y a
beaucoup d'acronymes comme ça où ils
vont sur le TFP aps complet on a 12 UV
là ils vont en faire qu'une partie en
mettant pour le CQP psge en mettant en
avant vraiment le module événementiel
donc ils vont pas être au même poste
c'est des gens qui vont être plus au
poste de contrôle pour vérifier avant de
rentrer dans les lieux ils vont plutôt
être en amont que vraiment à l'intérieur
et donc vous avez déjà eu des candidats
pour faire cette formation là alors sur
tout ce qui est événementiel nous sommes
en lien avec l'éducation nationale il y
a une communication qui est faite bien
entendu en parallèle en direction des
étudiants donc la cible est différente
bien entendu nous nous allons accès pour
l'emploi en tout cas axe
l'action de formation auprès des
demandeurs d'emploi qui vont être soit
déjà sur sur un souhait d'aller sur
cette action de formation soit qui n'ont
pas envisagé la formation d'agents de
sécurité et là on est sur des
compétences transférables c'est à dire
que nous avons par exemple des personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui à la recherche d'un
emploi d'agent d'accueil l'agent
d'accueil peut avoir des compétences
transférables vers le métier d'agent de
sécurité notamment accueil du public
prévention gestion des conflits il y a
d'autres métiers avec des compétences
transférables qui peuvent être
intéressés en tout cas les demandes
d'emploi peuvent être intéressés pour
s'orienter vers la sécurité d'où le fait
que nous mettions en place des ateliers
détection de potentiel pour faire
découvrir le secteur d'activité qui cet
atelier détection de potentiel et
découvertes du secteur est animé en lien
avec l'école de formation donc on a ESP
mais on a aussi d'autres organismes de
formation tels que le GRETA et l'ISCG de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et nous mettons
aussi à contribution les employeurs qui
d'un côté sont là pour des jobs dating
recruter des candidats aujourd'hui qui
sont immédiatement employables mais de
l'autre côté aussi susciter l'envie
d'aller vers le secteur de la sécurité
et faire découvrir les perspectives
d'évolution au-delà des JO 2024 de voilà
d'avoir une visibilité sur le métier les
conditions d'exercice du métier les
perspectives d'évolution et si la
personne ne souhaite pas évoluer vers ce
métier là mais c'est toujours un plus
dans son parcours professionnel
donc vous le disiez en début d'émission
il y a 25000 postes à pourvoir en
Île-de-France dans les Yvelines il y en
a combien à peu près et est-ce que du
coup vous avez déjà eu des candidats
nous avons des candidats sur les postes
nous travaillons avec des entreprises
clientes et non clientes puisque nous
organisons régulièrement des jobs dating
à destination des candidats qui
recherchent en tant qu'agent de sécurité
donc aujourd'hui c'est au fil de l'eau
en fonction des besoins des employeurs
donc certains ont déjà répondu aux
appels d'offres certains sont déjà
désignés pour pour justement contribuer
aux JO 2024 notre axe c'est aussi de
pouvoir les capter donc côté conseiller
entreprises de prendre contact avec ses
employeurs et de leur proposer de
s'associer à nous pour les aider dans
les besoins en recrutement alors Emily
barrad vous êtes la directrice
pédagogique pour l'école européenne de
sécurité privée vous proposez
différentes formations dans protecteur
de la sécurité est-ce que vous pouvez
nous les présenter oui alors on a la
formation classique donc pour être agent
de sécurité qui est le tfps qui est une
formation qui est un minimum de 175
heures
on fait aussi une spécialité incendie
qui s'appelle le sien en fait le métier
d'agent de sécurité et
un métier avec une partie commune et
beaucoup d'options autour donc on
commence à Jean de sécurité on peut
devenir après agent de sécurité
spécialisé en incendie devenir
responsable d'équipe de sécurité
incendie on peut aussi faire des
formations pour être agent de sécurité
armé qu'on appelle asradet on peut faire
de la protection rapprochée il y a
beaucoup de métiers autour de de cette
première formation qui est le TfT APS
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
que c'est le
tafps donc cette formation de 175 heures
qui est découpée en 12 UV et qui permet
à la fin d'obtenir son diplôme et donc
de faire une demande de carte pro pour
pouvoir travailler en tant qu'agent de
sécurité il vous faut absolument une
carte pro
une fois que vous avez la carte pro
le boulot il y en a c'est vraiment un
métier en tension les entreprises on a
beaucoup d'entreprises partenaires et
plus compliqué d'avoir des candidats que
de les placer après de les mettre à
l'emploi nous on propose des dispositifs
qui sont
faits avec le Pôle Emploi
donc sur la PEC qui est le adaptation de
poste de travail donc préparation
opérationnelle à l'emploi ou il y a
besoin de compétences complémentaires
l'employeur et partant bien entendu pour
former la personne faire appel à un
organisme de formation et les
engagements réciproques c'est d'un côté
nous avons un candidat qui va se former
de l'autre côté un employeur qui
s'engage
à le recruter notamment pour les
préparations opérationnelles à l'emploi
en individuel et ensuite on rentre dans
le détail mais tout ce qui est collectif
est en lien avec un organisme paritaire
collecteur donc un financement qui qui
est mobilisé qui est tout autre voilà ce
sont des formations en fait quand on
rentre dans un dispositif de PEC ça veut
dire que les gens qui sont qui rentrent
en formation ont déjà été en entretien
avec l'employeur et donc ont un poste
assuré à la sortie une fois qu'ils ont
leur diplôme et leur carte
professionnelle donc voilà c'est pas
juste faire une formation c'est une
formation plus un métier derrière
et ça c'était en général la crainte des
candidats de se dire bon ben je vais
faire une formation mais est-ce que je
vais trouver un travail derrière oui il
y a du travail mais est-ce que c'est un
travail uniquement pour les JO non parce
qu'il y a des besoins même aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de souci là-dessus on nous
avons des employeurs comme odor si je
pense aussi tu es quelques-uns mais
comme odeur 5 à 5 sécurités et d'autres
avec lesquels nous travaillons et qui
mobilisent des actions de formation et
d'adaptation au poste de travail et bien
merci à vous deux d'être venu en plateau
pour répondre à nos questions si vous
êtes intéressé du coup par toutes ces
formations n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur le site internet de Pôle emploi ou
sur le site de l'école européenne de
sécurité privée